Est-ce qu'on pourrait réfléchir si on n'avait pas de cerveau ?
Est-ce qu'on peut penser si on n'a pas de cerveau ?
Est-ce qu'on peut avoir conscience de soi-même si on n'a pas de cerveau ?
Faudrait déjà voir si quelqu'un n'avait pas de cerveau...
Et c'est le sujet de cette nouvelle série.
Ouais, il y a une nouvelle série à chaque vidéo.
J'en ai conscience, il en reste encore
deux nouvelles à lancer après celle-ci
et vous avez toutes celles qu'il y aura toute l'année.
Celle-ci, elle s'appelle les "Mental Fact" et aujourd'hui
on va voir comment vivre sans cerveau !
Alors, déjà ça existe.
Il y a eu plusieurs patients qui ont étés observés au cours de notre époque, contemporaine
Et on s'est aperçu qu'ils n'avaient alors, non pas, pas de cerveau,
mais quasiment pas de cerveau.
Quelques millimètres seulement lorsqu'on a fait des examens de leur boîte crânienne.
C'est là que ça devient intéressant !
- Et oui ma petite dame -
Parce qu'on a tendance à idéaliser le cerveau,
à se dire, plus le cerveau est gros, plus on est intelligent!
D'ailleurs les hommes ont un cerveau un peu plus gros que les femmes,
donc ils doivent être plus intelligents.
Ça n'a rien à voir, la preuve.
En s'attardant un peu sur le cas d'un homme de 50 ans,
qui était marié, qui avait deux enfants,
il travaillait dans l'administration.
Et il a un petit soucis, il a du mal à marcher.
Même quand il est à jeun, c'est pour te dire...
De là, il va consulter un médecin en 2007.
En posant quelques questions, l'équipe du médecin,
l'équipe du docteur Feuillet pour être très précis.
Il constate donc que depuis tout petit,
Il est traité pour un problème pour un problème qui s'appelle l'hydrocéphalie
L'hydrocéphalie c'est l'accumulation excessive du liquide céphalorachidien à l'intérieur de la boîte crânienne
C'est à dire que dans notre boîte crânienne, on a un cerveau, ok,
on a une boîte crânienne et bé, au milieu de tout ça, entre tout ça,
Il y a le liquide céphalorachidien qui sert un petit peu d'airbag aussi,
pour que quand on fait ça, le cerveau se cogne pas littéralement
Ça amortit un petit peu tout ça.
Et bé lui, il en a beaucoup trop!
À tel point que quand il était petit, quand il était enfant,
on a dû lui mettre un tuyau, comme ça, dans le crâne,
pour enlever un petit peu le liquide,
pour faire, heu, une dérivation...
un petit peu..., c'est sympathique.
Depuis, il a un petit robinet;
Non, il n'a pas de robinet, non!
Donc le médecin, pas fou!
Il se dit, quand il était petit,
il n'y avait pas les moyens actuels
Donc aujourd'hui, on va lui faire la totale :
IRM, scanners etc...
Ils font tout ça, ils regardent les images et là
BIM! Pas de cerveau. Pas de cerveau!
Il avait pas de cerveau, on a cherché,
il n'avait pas de cerveau.
C'est peut-être le premier troll d'internet.
C'était peut-être lui du coup, pas de cerveau,
et non, pas de cerveau...
Alors, pour bien comprendre,
il ne faut pas imaginer que le,
le tuyau que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
était vraiment dans son crâne.
En fait, c'était un tuyau qui faisait...
un mini tuyau hein,
qui faisait tout dériver à l'intérieur de son corps
pour éliminer en fait le surplus.
Et le tuyau s'était bouché depuis 30 ans.
Donc, dans son cerveau,
la marrée est montée on peut dire, tu vois?
Tout s'est rempli du liquide céphalorachidien.
Ça a prit tout l'espace et
plus ça prenait d'espace en fait,
plus ça s'accumulait et plus les structures cérébrales étaient repoussées au bord du crâne.
Donc c'est à dire, ça se remplissait comme ça
et ça repoussait toute la structure cérébrale
vraiment collée à la paroi crânienne.
Et là, vous vous dites :
Wow, mais comment il a fait?!
Alors, la première chose incroyable,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de dysfonctionnement
réellement de son cerveau
à part là, cette petite difficulté à marcher,
mais il n'avait pas de pertes de mémoire...
Les mauvaises langues ont tout de suite dit :
"Oui, mais il doit être plus bête que la moyenne..."
Et effectivement, il a un QI légèrement en dessous de la moyenne nationale qui est de 90-100.
Lui, il a un QI de 75.
Mais, il y a eu des cas de figures similaires à lui,
il y a eu d'autres cas. Un autre avec un QI de 126, un autre avec un QI de 130,
il y avait des surdoués qui avait ce problème.
En réalité, c'est là que l'on voit toute la plasticité du cerveau.
Le cerveau c'est une pâte à modeler
et il peut tout refaire.
On a longtemps cru qu'il y avait des
zones définies pour le cerveau,
ici il y a ça [x3]
C'est en partie vraie, de toute manière,
on n'a pas fini de découvrir, loin de là.
Mais ça, c'est une preuve réelle que le cerveau
peut se réadapter en permanence,
il peut se restructurer.
C'est vraiment quelque chose
de  plastique, d'étirable, de modulable.
Lors du scan, il n'ont pas pu voir les structures
situées au centre du cerveau.
Elles n'avaient pas disparues,
elles s'étaient simplement déplacées
ailleurs et restructurées différemment.
Comme je vous le disais,
ce n'est pas un cas isolé,
il y a eu d'autre cas,
il y a eu un doctorant en mathématiques
qui a été consulter le neurologue John Lorber.
Le doctorant en math avait un QI de 126, tranquille...
Et son encéphale était réduit à
une pellicule de moins d'un millimètre.
Qui était située juste au dessus de sa moelle épinière.
Le liquide céphalorachidien de ce mec
occupait 95% de sa boîte crânienne.
Mais si son cerveau n'avait pas pu évoluer,
par contre, son intelligence
avait évolué, son humour, tout!
Il y avait eu aussi une histoire comme ça d'un homme qui était décédé brutalement en 1914.
Et lors de l’autopsie, je crois qu'il avait 62 ans,
lors de l'autopsie, quand on a regardé, on s'est aperçu que lors d'un accident qu'il avait eu au cours de sa vie,
son cerveau avait été réduit en une espèce de marmelade, il avait été complétement bousillé.
Et pourtant, personne ne s'en était rendu compte,
c'est à dire que toutes ses fonctions ont remarchés, le cerveau s'était réadapté, c'était modifié.
Et il pouvait continuer à vivre normalement, personne ne s'en était rendu compte, même pas lui!
Alors voilà, je me dis que suite à tout ça, on peut arrêter de vouer un culte au cerveau en tant qu'organe.
Ce qui est important, c'est pas l'organe, sa taille, etc.
C'est, heu... sa puissance de plasticité.
On peut tout apprendre, à tous les âges.
On peut s'adapter à de nouvelles choses.
Notre cerveau, il est capable de tout faire en fait.
Et notre conscience est le fait de savoir
qu'on existe nous même,
de se reconnaître sur une photo par exemple
et le fait de pouvoir penser
n'est pas forcement lié au fait
que cet organe ait cette forme là,
cette géométrie là ou une taille et/ou
une masse plus ou moins importante qu'une autre.
J'espère que ce nouveau format
"Mental Fact" va vous plaire.
Il y en aura régulièrement sur cette chaine.
La prochaine vidéo que je vous sors,
je pense que je vais la sortir samedi matin.
Ça va être tous les résultats
de l’expérience "mouton-chèvre".
Expérience mentale que vous pouvez retrouver encore sur cette chaine si vous ne l'avez pas encore vue.
J'ai reçu 30.000 réponses, en fait
j'ai reçu plus de 30.000 réponses.
Mais je n'ai pas pris en compte ceux
qui n'ont pas mis leur adresse mail,
je voulais être sûr qu'il y ait
une seule réponse par participant.
Les résultats sont très intéressants,
vous verrez ça donc samedi à 11h00.
N'oubliez pas de cliquer sur la cloche
si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas de laisser
un pouce en l'air et de vous abonner à la chaine.
Et rendez-vous donc samedi à 11h00 je pense. Tchao!
[Musique Générique de Fin]